je sens les bouts mais les bons agité
mon corps blessé l'amour comme un
boomerang me revient des jours passés à
pleurer les larmes dingues d'un corps
que je t'avais donné
je sors le bout de la langue ton prénom
presque effacé tordu comme un pour me
rendre mon esprit la rejeté de ma
mémoire car la bringue et ton amour
monte je les ai
je sens des beaux mais des bonnes agitez
mon cœur blessé l'amour comme un
boomerang me revient des jours passés à
s'aimer comme des dingues comme de vous
relier
sache que ce cœur exemple pour être un
jour s'arrêter si comme un pour me
rendre je ne reviens pas me chercher peu
à peu je me déglingue victime de ta
cruauté
[Musique]
je sens des paumés des bombes j'étais
mon cœur blessé l'amour comme un
boomerang me revient des jours passés à
t'aimer comme une dingue
[Musique]
le mais c'est du coeur passer prends
garde à ce beau me rendre qui pourrait
te faire payer toutes ces tortures de
cinglé que tu m'as fait on dirait
[Musique]
une histoire vraie
ma raison va si étendre elle est prête à
chavirer sous les coups de pour me
rendre de flash-back enchaîné si un jour
je me flingue c'est à toi que je te
demande
[Musique]
je sentais pour mes dépenses agiter mon
cœur blessé l'amour qu'à main pour me
rendre me revient des jours passés à
pleurer des larmes d'un corps je t'avais
[Musique]
orange ne revient des jours passés la
nuit les larmes dingues d'un corps que
je t'avais donné
[Musique]
je remercie mon père d'avoir écrit et
composé cette chanson
jugé trop sulfureuse en 1974 merci à
Dany de l'avoir chanté
et d'avoir refusé d'en modifier les
paroles quand la télévision l'exigeait
merci bien sûr à Étienne Daho et ce soir
je te remercie toi dinos et Sébastian
pour avoir créé cette nouvelle version
merci à toi
merci de ton merci merci de m'avoir
permis de réinterpréter cette chanson
merci à l'Académie de César d'ouvrir sa
porte était grand temps
merci pour légendaire Serge Gainsbourg
pour cette oeuvre et tout ce que nous a
laissé et merci à ma mère qui me regarde
plein de bisous